this morning the united kingdom is
saying its final farewell to prince
philip queen elizabeth's husband of
nearly 74 years died last week
while the nation grieves the father
grandfather and great grandfather of
future kings of england
only a handful of mourners will be
inside st george's chapel at windsor
castle for the funeral services
holly williams is at windsor castle
hallie good morning to you
good morning this funeral has been
planned for years and the original guest
list was for 800
people but that's now been scaled back
to just 30 members because of covet
they'll wear face masks inside of st
george's chapel that's the same church
here at windsor castle
where harry and megan were married
by the standards of the royal family
famous for its pomp
philip's funeral will be a bare-bones
ceremony
which is apparently what he would have
wanted members of the military have been
practicing
their parts for a man who was a hero of
the second world war
the queen had to make some difficult
decisions about which family members
could come
she is saying farewell to someone to who
she was married for
73 years that must be
a very very profound thing in anybody's
life
the coffin will be carried in a
specially modified
land rover that philip helped design
wow his friend giles brandreth told us
phillip
along with other royals loved the
british suv
i think he thought well it's sensible i
need to get there land rover's very good
cars
couldn't drive it recently but at least
i'll be seen out in one
[Music]
after her coronation in 1953 philip was
consort to the queen for nearly seven
decades
known for his charity work and his lack
of political correctness
but the british public knew very little
about the private life of the monarch
and her husband
he said you know we're not personalities
we're not celebrities
we are members of a royal family here to
do
a duty to do a job the younger
generations of the royal family
are different some have been
scandalously divorced
harry's recent bombshell interview with
oprah and his fractured relationship
with his brother
mean many eyes will be on him during the
funeral
philip will be laid to rest later on
today inside the royal vault
in saint george's chapel kings and
queens have been buried in the chapel
for centuries including king henry viii
michelle holly thank you well cbs news
will have
live coverage of the funeral our special
remembering prince philip
airs this morning at 9 30 eastern time